so we've been tracking the rise of
Elizabeth Warren in the 2020 Democratic
primary for a while now I already told
you that Joe Biden has had a sort of up
and down polling sequence Bernie Sanders
had some ups and downs in his polling
Elizabeth Warren on the other hand has
had a slow but steady climb from the
sort of four to five percent range to
roughly ten percent now which is where
she is as of the latest polls and she's
been doing it not with extraordinary
flash or viral videos or whatever else
she's been doing it by campaigning
substantively and doing interviews where
she lays out substantive policy doing
town halls and talking to all sorts of
voters including right-wing voters in
read parts of the country and I like the
fact that this is what she's doing I
don't know if it'll carry her to the
nomination but I like the fact that this
is her approach and over the weekend she
did a town hall in Oakland California
where 6500 people showed up to see
Elizabeth Warren this was at Laney
college on Friday night 6500 people
waited in line outside the venue the
entire thing was delayed an hour because
there were so many people trying to get
in and once again it was a super
substantive event based on policy and
ideas Elizabeth Warren talked about her
proposal to end corruption her proposals
to cut money in politics proposals that
would directly help the middle class
actually not like Trump's tax plan
student loan debt proposals gun violence
related proposals the only thing about
it that you could criticize is that
because it was so busy and it started so
late she ended up not taking questions
from the audience so it ended up being
more of a rally or speech than it was a
town hall so I want to give you the pros
and cons of what's going on here with
Elizabeth Warren so as someone who has
been running a substantive issue based
campaign I love to see Elizabeth Warren
draw these types of crowds 6500 for
someone who is yes she's a well-known
senator but she is not the sort of cult
of personality a celebrity that
some other people in politics are I
think it's absolutely fantastic I've
also been critical of Elizabeth Warren
before even though I love her policy
ideas that she is not the most likable
or the most relatable candidate at the
large level I have seen her relate to
people individually in a way that is
quite relatable and makes her more
likable but to see a huge crowd of
people fired up by campaign finance
reform or ending foreign influence on
our elections by foreign countries
dealing with structural inequality it's
awesome to see people fired up by that
and turning out by the thousands to hear
her talk about that and so there are two
ways that this could go for Elizabeth
Warren in the next few months if
Elizabeth Warren can keep gaining the
one to one-and-a-half percentage points
per month in the polls which is roughly
what she's been doing for the last
several months if she can do that and
outlast the people that are polling 1%
the people that are polling 2% who are
going to start dropping out either by
choice or by force as the Democratic
National Committee's primary primary
debate requirements go into force after
the second debate and then in the third
and fourth debates she could end up in a
really strong position by the time the
fourth debate is all said and done in
October and then it's a question of who
does the progressive vote sort of
coalesce around as a coalesce around
Bernie does it coalesce around Elizabeth
Warren who I believe clearly are the non
Biden frontrunner at this point in time
could change but that's what it's
looking like right now that's one way it
could go and maybe the debates would
help her achieve that on the other hand
though as I said what I see is Elizabeth
Warren's biggest weakness is she doesn't
debate very well especially in a debate
with a whole bunch of other people I
don't know the first debate there's so
many people there splitting it into two
like a first a and first B debate and I
believe it's random I don't know how
many people will be on each one of those
debate stages
I don't 100% know how she gets the exact
right type of attention in that format
that will advance her campaigns
difficult lis and part of it is she
actually can go deep on a lot of these
issues right she's got the right ideas
she has the experience she clearly has
the intelligence the fact that the worst
Trump has been able to do with her is
call her Pocahontas and talk about her
Native American DNA fiasco which was a
fiasco the way it was handled that
actually suggests to me that Republicans
are kind of scared of her when you look
at some of the issues that the country
is dealing with right now and you look
at Elizabeth Warren's experience her
work in consumer and financial the cfpb
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
when you look at her work on income
inequality it lines right up with some
of the biggest problems that we're
facing in the United States and the fact
that all the right has been able to do
is say Pocahontas suggests to me she
could do really well against Donald
Trump and not that Bernie wouldn't as
well so I think it'll be very
interesting to see how does her message
come through in a debate because it does
not allow especially with however many
people is it gonna be 8 or 10 for each
of the two debates I don't know I don't
know if she can go into the depth that
is required for her to appeal to people
if you go to her rallies she's going
into detail about her proposals and
talking to voters about them and that is
part of why she has been gaining we'll
see if that translates to the debates
and for me it's more a question of the
dynamics of the Democratic primary and
just realizing that in these large
massive formats she's not the most
relatable she's not a particularly good
debater once we start the debate phase
which is in a few weeks
it's the debates themselves that are
going to influence the next several
months of the campaign and probably have
a significant role in defining who
ultimately wins the primary my concern
is it's not Elizabeth Warren's area of
expertise but I'm sure that she knows
this and that she's preparing in person
she relates really well to people maybe
less so and debates with ten other
people I'm curious to see what people in
the audience think about this you know
unlike Hillary Clinton who narrowly lost
in 2016
Warren is actual
further to the left unlike our 2016
nominee Hillary Clinton Warren doesn't
have the investigative baggage around
her and the admittedly fake but
impactful scandals that Hillary had like
Benghazi and the email stuff so there's
every indication to me that Republicans
would rather not have Donald Trump run
against Elizabeth Warren but let me know
what you think and let me know what you
believe the debates will bring I know
that there are people who vehemently or
vehemently disagree with me about what
the debates will bring and how they will
affect polling but let me know